with the crowd chanting her name last
weekend heaven Fitch became the first
female to win a North Carolina state
championship in wrestling every wrestler
she beat at this year's tournament was a
boy but it was a different story in
Kansas this week where more than a
hundred young women competed in the
state's first ever girls wrestling
tournament Jamie yuccas has the story
she's a country girl no stranger to hard
work and nothing can keep her down on
the farm if they're quick or anywhere
else 18-year old Nicky Moore has been
wrestling boys for years one of five
girls on the Nickerson high varsity
squad it's the kind of confidence that
wasn't always there Moore still
remembers being bullied as a kid I was
really quiet I kind of walked with my
head down I stayed by myself why I
didn't think I was good enough to be
where I am today where she is today is
number one in the state in her female
weight class and third in the nation a
hopeful for the 2024 Olympics
hey how'd that feel her mother angel is
her biggest cheerleader she says
wrestling was a godsend
she's now top of her class she just got
signed to a college can you wish for
anything more for your kid a kid poised
to take her first state title
that's only possible here in Kansas
because of this father-daughter duo who
went to the mat to give girls a sport of
their own it kind of takes a girl that's
serious about wrestling to convince a
coach that it's worthy endeavor coach
Doug Kretzer thought his daughter Maya
would be a team manager but she decided
she wanted in on the action her freshman
year it was never easy
competing and being on a team full of
boys you wrestle with these people like
it's really like difficult it would take
four years for girls wrestling to become
an official sport too late for Maya but
not for hundreds of others like
Nickerson heavyweight Matty Miller who
says wrestling gave her self-confidence
I don't think I would be such like an
outgoing and a happy person like I am
now if I didn't do wrestling Miller
walked into regionals undefeated what is
the strategy I want to go get a state
title as a freshman like let's go I
didn't have to look very far today to
see a lot of girls with the big smiles
on their faces and and excited about
their wins and heartbroken when they
lost because they felt like they could
have come they had a chance to compete
do you wish you had been able to
participate in something like this it's
my girls now they can definitely go take
the championship so I definitely am just
excited they can do that
the Nickerson lightweight now a state
champ paving the way for a new
generation of girls so you're all-in
with this I am all-in yes this is what I
want to do for the rest of my life
for CBS this morning Saturday Jamie
yuccas McPherson Kansas this piece just
reinforces what I tell my daughter over
and over again you know find something
and it will bring you out the passion of
bunch of joy yeah under Joel and there's
a beauty in sport in what it can do for
confidence especially for young women I
remember doing a story on a female
wrestler 20 years ago it's great to see
where they've gotten to now